how did a very warm welcome to the
Deutsche Welle world economic forum
debate coming to you this time from
Jakarta the capital of Indonesia now
Indonesia is a country which spans some
17,000 islands and just six months ago a
new government was sworn in here
economically speaking East Asia remains
the fastest growing region in the world
in a world which is still recovering
from the global financial crisis so many
argue that the underlying factor behind
every financial crisis is one thing the
absence of trust can we afford to live
in a world where there's no trust in the
way business is done our proposition
today is trust or bust how can trust be
strengthened at the intersection of
business and society to discuss this I
have a wonderful panel for you let me
introduce you to them starting with
Ethel sing Ethel thing is the group
president or asia-pacific of the
coca-cola company the world's largest
soft drinks maker Frankie osmart vijaya
chairman and CEO of cinema's
agribusiness and food one of Indonesia's
largest conglomerates Suzy pooja stuti
is an aviation tycoon an entrepreneur
and activist a school dropout but above
all the minister of match I'm affairs
and Fisheries and a very popular
minister at that from what I've heard
then we have it by outside who's
chairman of the Indonesian trade union
confederation confrontational combative
and charismatic a voice in Indonesia's
labor movement and finally mark visa
president and CEO of packed us a a
non-governmental organization for
development ladies and gentlemen please
join me in giving a warm welcome to our
panel
I don't let me start with you you come
from a big corporate company yes you've
done extremely well wherever you work
beat in China or India and in India you
had 22 consecutive quarters of growth
why should you care about trust at all I
mean making the profits that you need to
make well you know Trust is the very
basic foundation without which I believe
business is not going to thrive I've
been fortunate working for the coca-cola
company that operates in over 200
countries and we've been around for over
one hundred twenty eight years and
brands to us mean a lot with of course
brand coca-cola is a leading brand brand
is a promise and a great brand is a
promise kept and without trust consumers
are not going to buy a brand that that
they consume so we believe that it's at
the absolute fundamental to doing
business we'll come back to that
absolves we talk more about the brand
but Frankie you're also a the head of a
large empire surely it's the dollar
which is driving your business and not
some kind of nebulous concept of trust
well I think it's a quite fortunate that
my father established cinemas group
which is already about 76 years 77 years
coming and he said Trust is more
important than his life so this is built
in our DNA actually as a corporate and I
think this is some very fortunate that
we do everything based on trust and we
can give i can give you example that
especially now ugly business which we
developed already about 300 more in
thread school 40,000 students and about
hundred fifty clinics surrounding so
that we really give a lot of interaction
with the with the community so that
wherever we operate they really
appreciate our present that that trust
building is also important to interact
in indonesia they said that the canal t
that science so we need to communicate
our philosophy
and sincerely what we try to do with
them and really benefit the society if I
let me turn to you now you've often been
in confrontation with companies you
brought this city Jakarta to a
standstill with your strikes do you
believe business leaders when they tell
you trust is a part of my DNA trust as a
part of our core principle of our
business of course yeah we need the
investment come to the Indonesia we need
a lot of employer come to the Indonesia
yeah but the other side we need Welford
we need the increasing purchasing power
not only increasing the economic growth
like Indonesia and the propping
countries in the world a lot of
developing country make increasing in
economic grudge but the other side they
have the genie increasing Gini index
also it means we have not up get the
income for the people including for the
labor and it means economic growth only
benefit for middle up class not be the
low including labor we go to that in
larger detail but I want to first don't
know get a voice from the government now
Suzie you are now in the government
there's very low trust levels of CEOs
but you're on the government and
government leaders had even lower trust
levels then CEOs do people trust you
less now that you've drunk the
government of President in October uh of
things somehow in my let's let's go back
to my what what I had in my life that's
actually I I starting from dropout from
my school then up to know is all built
on based on trust they're actually I've
done my best as much as I can't and be
inconsistent and finally people give me
a trust also when i started my fisheries
businesses I start my export because the
Japanese give me a trust to to give us a
red cloth l see that we can export in
the first time because it was almost
impossible 1996 on the crisis starting
in Indonesia to have but to borrow money
from the bank to be able to export so my
first export was basically based on on a
trust of one of my Japanese buyer who
trust to give us a hundred percent red
clothes LC and we can deliver the
products and then also leather on up to
the aviation because then the bank trust
and we can grow up there is need
sometimes to do to build up and earn the
trust from the associate e to the
business person but by the time it takes
me four years to to get the first 2i
graph from the money from the bank to be
able to buy the two first aircraft and
then we had the tsunami service and then
we continue with the outline business
because people trust our our flights and
so you moved from business to government
have you seen your trust levels drop
since then um I don't I don't see on
that point I had to tell all of you hear
that in fact Susie has the highest
approval rating of all ministers in
Indonesia so Armas DC still has not lost
her trust value let me just draw in a
mark at this level mark you work in
development in you off often implement
projects for governments in different
parts of the world as well as for
foundations like coca-cola 150 projects
in 30 countries how difficult is it for
you to convince people that trust is a
currency which is important for the
greater good of society well I think
it's a fascinating question I'm you know
Trust is such an emotional personal
thing and so how do you take something
that's so intangible like that and
somehow quantify it make it tangible
like a currency that and of itself the
challenge you know Trust is I think
hard to get and easy to lose and so I
think that where it starts is it starts
by the very essence of why there's an
engagement do people it's no different
than with with individuals or families
our communities it all comes from a
genuine sincerity and if there's a
genuineness of shared values of shared
intent of a translation from
stakeholders to joint shareholders of
something then you have a good basis for
that dialogue that can can through
transactions of fulfilling the promise
be proof points of why we should have
that trust you see the older if you have
made a very strong a commitment to
making trust a core value in your
business and your operations in your
lifestyle but the statistics show that
in fact just twenty percent of the
general public believes what business
leaders tell them and believe that
business leaders take ethical and moral
decisions and get a survey by le monde
shows that eighty-six percent of the
general public believe that it is
possible for business to take decisions
which are for the good of society at the
same time they enhance profit so
obviously there's a big gap between the
perception of the general public about
trust and what they believe can be done
Frankie let me start with you again on
this issue now your company's sinar mas
has had a rough time you had a stage in
2009 2010 various multinationals
boycotted palm oil from your company
Nestle and you reliever then recently in
2013 you had another problem with smog
and haze due to the burning of palm oil
plantations yours is one of the
companies which was singled out as being
perhaps responsible how do you deal with
this drop in trust how do you reorganize
your value chain to make sure that the
trust comes back from the people well
it's a very good question and thank you
for the question because this is the
opportunity for us to really clarify and
gain the trust back actually we have
done a lot in the sense that
for the policy which the government has
given us we always try to do more than
that for example zero burning policy we
have adopted that furry let's say the
government said this year start and then
we already started three years back and
also non pit planting actually the
government already given us three meters
that you could plant the below three
meters so we have said with zero peat
soil planting for the few years back so
these are the few things that we have
done but I think we had not been
communicating that enough so maybe this
is a good platform to really communicate
each of initiative that we are doing and
actually i'm also very fortunate to
co-chair the pisa agro so called
partnership for initial sustainable
agriculture so how can we also help not
only just ourselves but the industries
of the palmer industry and other crops
to be sustainable and that platform
really built trust together between the
private public partnerships and how can
we build that trust basically is to have
the measurement the KPIs and really they
feel that the sincere care is there and
we have been successfully having about
three years launching of the episode
grow and we have 86,000 farmers has been
feeling that that this platform has been
helping them in terms of the elevating
their poverty line by increasing their
yield and also certainly the
productivity and their income other can
you measure something like trust you
said trust those are important part yeah
sure we actually measure trust in
corporate reputation which is another
proxy for trust and I'm very pleased to
announce that you know overall company
like ours when you go around the world
again 200 countries and we don't measure
every country but but most of the major
ones we have a very high trust rating
you know consumers you know we
consumers consume over a couple of
billion drinks per day and they vote
with their wallet every day and and and
this is across the board and they won't
do that if they didn't trust the quality
of our products consumers today by from
companies that they trust we believe in
sustainability as core to a foundation
of doing business this is not a CSR that
we do on the side somewhere every aspect
of a value chain whether it is farmers
that we deal with in Africa and Asia are
the parts around the world we work with
them we work with their yields we work
with you know for example in India drip
irrigation partnering with different
different people within a value chain to
make sure that we can help them sustain
a good livelihood Iqbal talked about
employer employment and wages etc so you
know we ensure that across the value
chain we are supporting different
stakeholders but the point is that
you're obviously selling the highest
number of soft drinks in the world so
but you must be doing something right a
coca-cola but at the same time I mean
sales are falling and there's
coca-cola's projected to lose some 2,000
employees this year and this also been
controversy about various projects which
coca-cola has taken for example in
Britain the anti-obesity project
coca-cola want to set up some 70 parks
fitness parks and that was there's a
huge outcry amongst the public and
amongst many experts that this is a
disingenuous attempt to distract from
the fact that coca-cola carries a lot of
sugar so at the same time I think one
has to be very careful about where the
trust factor lies so obviously you're
also facing some tough challenges oh
sure there are there are issues there
are challenges across the board you know
you mentioned obesity that's one of them
the water we were at one point in time
challenged on the water usage but you
know we're in the water business and we
were challenged with water but i'm very
happy to say that in lots of countries
around the world we actually put back
more water into the ground than we use
in our products and we've made a
commitment but that by the year
20 20 will be water neutral that means
we will actually through rain water
harvesting check dams other innovative
processes use less water put back more
water into the ground than we take out
obesity it's a complex issue it's about
calories in versus calories out we want
to be part of the solution we want to be
able to work trust you to be part of the
solution or that is the bottom line here
are people don't trust you because they
say that you are trying to use a
branding technique you're trying to use
a program to actually distract from the
problem there are some people who say
that absolutely and you britain is one
example there are a couple of others but
by far enlarged when you look at the
couple of hundred countries in which we
operate we have what we call the Golden
Triangle civil society government and
corporates we are the facilitator that
brings all together to find solutions
what I want to be part of a solution we
have an issue obesity is an issue you
know now let's not debate as to how it's
been caused let's find the solution and
I think when you look at working with
government working with NGOs and civil
society other companies we're finding
solutions and for creating trust that is
the currency about creating trust now
Suzie you are facing many challenges as
well as i mentioned indonesia comprises
of some 17,000 islands the second
largest coastline in the world and you
are the minister for fisheries so you
have a lot of challenges ahead of you
how are you dealing in terms of policy
tackling some of the issues that you are
facing right now okay so the the biggest
problem in indonesia that I'm facing
when I was in my office is the fact that
Indonesian the second-largest cause the
line in the world but number five in
Southeast Asia that's put very far kept
which I have to bring them together in
line why that's happened because
Indonesians natural resources basically
fisheries had been taken so much by so
many illegal fishing in Indonesia which
then I was seeing it's almost impossible
to
handle it in smooth away so what we do I
issued a moratorium policy for the ex
foreign fishing vessel which indicating
that many of them duplicating the
license to fish in the water so those
early days we had about 1,300 fishing
vessel that operates in our water but
duplicate both it's at least five to
seven times in some of them even ten
times and that's what costs in the last
15 years 115 companies in around Java
and few islands are collapsed because
they don't have raw material anymore had
been taken away in the sea and that was
also because we allowing transhipment in
the sea to basically taking an exporting
direct in the middle of the sea so no no
no checkpoint harbor no nothing so the
second policy that I made it was the
banning transhipment in the middle of
the sea so everything has to be go to
the board and checkpoint and we also
indicating that had been so many an
appropriate practices on those illegal
fishing with the slavery issues and many
things and this will cause Indonesia
there's nobody want to invest anything
in fisheries because there's no picture
is not a interesting picture that yes
potential are there and actually we can
be one of the most dominant and
important player in NC food businesses
with our sources sighs yeah iqbal I want
to ask you now you've been working a lot
on improving a lot of workers in
Indonesia and you've been focusing on
things like minimum wage has been a very
important issue for you the Health
Scheme insurance pension for workers how
confident are you with the new
government here with president Joko
Widodo that the workers is there an
environment of trust where the workers
needs will be addressed yeah
yes we have concerned about the some
priority issue labor first about the
decent wages against the low wages
policies and social security reform and
against the precarious work or
outsourcing and then against the union
busting and etc so the new president the
new government in Indonesia we cannot
look looking for forward and make the
new regulation for better life for the
labors for example in this year's jokowi
president have to sign about the
government regulation pension system
follow the law last year's in the
November president already sign but
until now president not yet sign for the
pension system well you know we need the
pension see I don't know why I don't
know i think the knowledge cheetah
program the names of the jehovahs
president he he called about the pension
system and have insurance for the people
but until now he doesn't sign the
regulation of the pension system it
means in july of this year's workers
cannot getting the pension no
implementation of the pension system in
Indonesia but I want to ask you now you
have often talked about taking the
militant way in the labor movement
having these massive strikes 1 million
people on the streets you bring the city
to a standstill and you've described
that as a means to an end to improve the
lives of workers but will that create
trust where companies trust you if you
bring things to a standstill yes we
because we don't understand what do we
do when government still interests and
focus only in fight the lot of
investment but the other said the
government cannot implement it the rules
the rule is already the law is already
but cannot implement it like decent
wages pension system health insurance
labor still limited getting the health
insurance a lot of people including
labor come to the hospital reviews from
the hospital this is problem a lot of
outsourcing in the step on enterprise
step on enterprise have the government
but still use the outsourcing or
precarious workers Frankie how do we get
out of this paradox now this is a
problem which is not you know it's
Universal is just not limited to
Indonesia where you have growth but that
growth is unevenly distributed they can
be no trust a phase uneven grow through
the disparity between rich and poor
keeps growing I certainly agree what
this parity is to be bringing to the
closest as possible and to be fair to
the taco is and Jake our administration
I think they're just six months so
there's a lot of problems that that has
to be to be what you call it paradise
suddenly this is very important priority
for the labor issues I think but I have
a confidence that our government is
doing the right things first of course
because of the currency has been
weakened because US dollar has been
strengthened against all other currency
and then the commodity prices came down
quite substantially so the buying power
has been reduced by twenty to thirty
percent so that this may be one of the
concentration in terms of
the priority in how to make sure that
we're coming out from this temporary
slowdown so that everybody can gain from
this economic growth I fully agree with
Iqbal that we need to put more attention
on that how to find the middle ground to
make sure that when the company grow the
the country grow the workers also feel
the we call it worth i would be taken
care of so i think that is a very fair
statement but we just had to be a little
bit patient because as again the
president has said with just six months
there's a lot of debottlenecking that
has to be done so that trust has to be
developed among within exactly in valle
stakeholders and the government yeah I
might say in I mean this is the thing I
see in this new government it's a big
actually how you call it they're very
keen to change things and change is also
word that is attract me to join to take
the part of the government role and it
is a lot of things that we have to
change from from a different management
perspective and also in a way that the
the economy had been growth so far I do
agree with by what by eight Ball said
that's the growth of the economy is not
deflecting into the prosperity of them
adapt to basically the lowest or the
group of people that is the labor and
really really the people in the villages
but I think the government are put
already they they they effort and the
interest that they are of course we have
to do battle the first thing is the fuel
subsidized that have been taking so much
of the country money every year we
almost spent 400 the trillions it is
about four forty billion dollars into
subsidizing few
and I told you before that illegal
fishing is using almost almost a quarter
of the whole country fuel consumption so
you see those subsidized had been
misused and had been hard for the
country and now without this dis
inefficiency in fuel subsidized we
expecting that they can do better and we
see we struggle with the with the with
the budgeting month also since also and
I see we cannot change that much either
in this year of budgeting our locations
because the budget that we are running
and spending in this 2015 is basically
designed by the government before which
different priorities on things so yeah
because I fuel subsidies as I've been
reading is a very controversial issue in
Indonesia let me just bring in athol
once again and turning away from
Indonesian politics for a sense for a
minute Ethel as we was talking but I
mentioned those anti-obesity campaign
just as an example of public trust now
obviously coca-cola is doing a lot of
other work which is trying to contribute
back to society but to what extent is
trust a competitive advantage for a
corporate company like yours oh I think
it's a huge competitive advantage if
consumers trust you trust your quality
to trust your product trust the values
that the brand the company stands for
they actually vote with their wallet
they buy your products you know AC
Nielsen did a study over 30,000
consumers around the world and in fact
was interesting that study found that an
especially in Asia Pacific in Asia
sixty-four percent of consumers were
actually preferred to buy products from
a company that they would trust and a
company that would would work toward
sustainability towards the environment
to a social well-being and I think
that's important 21st century companies
have got to focus not only on you know
the the profit angle if you will but but
also on
balanced scorecard I mean we have to be
able to grow our businesses without
growing the carbon footprint for example
you have to grow our businesses with
using less on per unit of electricity if
you see a variation in trusting are you
worked in four continents and research
shows that small and medium sized
companies run by families are trusted
the world over apart from Asia so what
are the retail variations you do you see
that where trust is placed in well if
people have a bad experience if you've
had bad experience and in today's world
with the internet with you know mobile
technology something that goes wrong
that that new spreads like wildfire I
mean almost instantaneously you can get
that news elsewhere so I think you know
it's it's an evolving changing dynamics
you know I wouldn't be able to comment
it why people in in Asia trusts you know
family businesses lesson than others
maybe there's been a bad experience that
that people in communities have had with
with the certain companies exploiting
communities for example but clearly the
world over and we operate as i said the
world over and we found the many great
companies around the world you know not
just are as many great companies around
the world if you contribute to society
and if you give back to society you're
going to be around for 100 years so
whether it's a chevron in Nigeria or
coca-cola in the US or in other parts of
the world if you contribute back to
society and that is both for companies
that are privately owned they're great
examples are privately owned on
companies of entrepreneurs whom people
trust a lot and the several examples
around the world so I would just say
that you know trust it doesn't matter
whether you're publicly owned privately
owned multinational or limited in a
certain geography it all depends on the
values that you live by research has
shown that actually geography does play
a certain role in which companies are
trusted the research has shown for
example the BRICS countries India cha
Russia are less trusted companies from
these countries and the country which is
most trusted I'm pleased to report this
is not my research is Germany followed
by Switzerland Sweden and Canada and
that's because they believe public
perception against all public perception
is that these countries pay more
attention to looking after employees
communities and the environment but
that's by the by mark I want to ask you
is there a trade off when companies put
trust at the core of their business is
there a trade-off and if companies are
not trustworthy can they go bust yeah
iiii think so i think way to be careful
if you use putting trust at the core of
your business as a methodology to gain
greater sales it will be seen as
disingenuous and backfire and so I think
that it comes back to I'm sorry to be a
broken record but you know what is the
the intent of a shared values with folks
that engage with you in a business
transaction and if you're trying to
manipulate your image PR or trying to be
seen as trustworthy people will see
through that and it's the same with
people right it's no different sure
there's Geographic differences um
edelman's done a lot of research on
trust and and and some of the the data
shows that that it's true I think one of
the things that can happen when you have
had a bad experience I don't think that
necessarily kills an opportunity for
trust I think a bad experience admitted
honestly openly and then rectified can
actually ironically deepen trust and so
it's all about that genuineness and you
can fake trust is what your father you
can give it a really good try and I
think it'll lat it'll work for a long
time but at the end of the day
particularly in communities where
there's not a lot of fun jable resources
where you know you're earning a dollar
two dollars a day you lose trust very
quickly if there's not authenticity you
know that's it's a question of
authenticity Suzie I have to come back
to you because from what I have heard
and read about you it's not what you say
it's what you do your life was
transformed you wrote by our own
admission during the 2004 tsunami what
is the story there okay so I had to
rough on those days still about a month
and running my fisheries business taking
the life lobster and the fresh fish to
Jakarta and then the tsunami happened we
help the people for two weeks that was
only the plan but then people i'll keep
the plane here i said i can't i don't
have enough gas anymore to run free
flights so then the trust from all the
NGOs basically to chapel our aircraft
and there are we starting our our our
our charter business and then we get
more and more and more so actually to
business that i have starting by but it
don't bling this plans and helping the
people of the tsunami in indonesia was
the worst affected country during the
tsunami and i believe a thing you write
that sincerity and Genuity are very
important actually to gain the trust of
doing the trust in the first place but
for the long run commitment depth you
you keep you you you give share of what
you earn back to the to the to the
stakeholders thought to your buyer or to
your customer and just starting with
those two airplanes you now have more
than 30 airplanes in your airliner
Christie I'll draft not gon it's called
Susi air yes I so I I always say to my
Japanese buyer i put my name that's a
life guarantee oh so for the quality
thank you that's to hold the trust
review I won't miss the round because I
can't change my name that's what I said
no Frankie will Suze talks about honesty
and sincerity and trust I mean most
people simply don't associate this with
a business right now you are associated
with so many boardrooms you know so many
directors the associated many companies
is trust a boardroom agenda or is it as
something that HR doesn't sounds good
like diversity can one make that a
boardroom agenda the concept of trust
well I think the as I said is very lucky
that my father a character Vijaya has
put that in the forefront of everything
so he said Trust is more important than
his life then this become our guiding
principle and has been embedded in the
in our in our other companies are like
your company's is that so basically all
all the group's company has been these
are the basic things everybody has to
understand this and we translate that
into our action so in in all the
business plan we always allocate certain
it's not just CSR but more than that how
we accompany the site the people on the
ground to really benefit from what we
will be doing so to gain the trust is
not it's not built in one day but it
takes time so we have been around for
morning nearly 80 years so i hope we
gain some trust in it no thank you Frank
even obviously your company as you say
it's part of your DNA but I'm still kind
of worried about the broader corporate
aspect and the road of trust there well
what do you feel you've listened to what
everybody is saying you've listened to
the government voice you've listened to
the corporate voices how do you feel are
you optimistic about trust being at the
centre of Labor Relations you have to
deal with trust with companies but
there's also a lack of trust within and
between different unions yeah we should
be optimistic for the life because all
must be gone we cannot back for the
experience we need the future for
example in Indonesia and developing
country we have paradox economic grouch
yeah and we can look if you look in the
employer side for example in the Nike
Adidas paid the tiger wood for the show
in the television 5 million dollars paid
labor for the salary per month
approximately in Indonesia 2040 it is
not fair so we need
fairness we need fair trade not free
trade only okay there's no one here I
think from Nike at the moment to respond
to your your comments I want to ask you
mark a final question listening to what
Iqbal had to say just now is there a
disconnect about what we mean by trust a
company means my trust delivering on
time giving a good product like
coca-cola but what advance talking about
is fairness and ethics and in an
underpinning business is there a
fundamental disconnect about how we deal
with this issue of trust yeah I think so
i think that's part of the issue you
know some of the elamans research talks
about what what industries think builds
up trust and what then consumers think
about build up trust and you if you if
you if as an industry you look at the
quality of your services for example and
you think that's the thing that builds
up trust and you spend a lot of time
measuring that how well people see your
quality you get this false sense of
trust when consumers or people in the
community where your plants might be
value something else is building up
trust you have this gap you don't
communicate and so I think it's
important to have an ongoing honest
conversation I think one of things eight
ball you mentioned is is really key that
that trust is such a human emotion such
an intangible thing that that that
transparency is key to making it more
tangible when you have and you're not
afraid to share and to show and to be
found out then trust comes even when
things aren't as much as right as they
should be and that in encourage dialogue
and so I think if you can make sure we
have an honest dialogue about what
certain people see as critical to trust
and compare that how we see it we begin
to start the conversation that's that's
rueful and I think we've had a very
interesting conversation so far and to
my great surprise I forget be a lot of
divergences in approach the idea of
trust but i am very pleasantly surprised
there is a great deal of commonality on
the importance of trust and what it
needs to have what needs to be done to
have mutual trust so I'm going to give
each banners 30 seconds to give me there
one quick take away as to how they can
build trust in their area of what
starting with you Frankie 30 seconds
well rome is not built in one day so
us has to be embedded in the corporate
and the societies so that really we can
build up the trust overtimes it man yeah
we need in investment come to the our
countries but the others it we need the
decent wages prosperity by Muto ultras
partnership equality transparency and
accountability we can build the trust
thank you at all well trust is a
fundamental and foundation of what we do
and I said it earlier a brand is a
promise in a great brand is a promise
kept thank you that was short and sweet
suthi Trust is very important especially
for the government to continue built up
and give its prosperity to the people we
need them to trust us and transparency
and good governance is his need to
enforce the trusses to be there without
that government would not able to
influence and do good for the people
thank you märklin I think having a
paradigm shift and seeing engagement
communities not as communities as
stakeholders but as shareholders for the
long-term perspective goes a long way to
engendering trust thank you well that
brings our session at to an end now the
absence of trust has great potential to
derail our the gains we've made socially
and economically I think all of us here
sitting on this podium agree that it's
really important all of us business the
government and society with more focus
on not just value but values not just
financial gain but the ethics which
underlie our interaction it's time to
put trust back at the heart and center
of our relations that was the DW world
economic forum debate coming to you from
Jakarta thank you very much for joining
us wherever you are thank you also to
the audience who's sitting with me here
in Jakarta and above all to our
wonderful panelists for stimulating and
lively debate on the issue of trust
you
you